despite the internet being cut off
across most of the country Iraqi
protesters have found a way to upload
videos onto social media sites that
appear to show live fire and tear gas
clouds these are pictures Iraq's
government doesn't want you to see they
paint a picture of what's happening on
the ground and help explain why there
have been many deaths and injuries over
the past few days the protesters are not
holding anything in their hands except
for Iraqi flags they're calling for the
most basic of rights employment and
services we need safety and an amnesty
law that takes people out of the secret
and public prisons Iraq has become full
of secret prisons the authorities are
building prisons only they're not
building hospitals or schools it's
relatively better now the curfew has
been removed I hope that decisions made
by the head of Parliament and the Prime
Minister are applied on the ground
because the Iraqi people have become
bored of all the promises we hope that
these decisions are applied the
protesters are angry over what they say
is government corruption and lack of
access to basic needs a curfew that's
been in place in Baghdad has now ended
and the situation is still tense
despite the lifting of the ban here in
Baghdad Tahrir Square the focal point
for the protesters is nowhere near as
busy as it should be as you can see
there's a big heavy security presence
now what the protesters are doing is
they're gathering in streets around her
career square which is what they've done
in the last few days what they're trying
to do is get a critical mass together
and come into the square the protests
are not just in the capital but across
the south and central part of Iraq and
now there's also a political crisis
brewing on Saturday Parliament was to
convene for an emergency session to
discuss the protests it never met three
major political bloc's refused to let
their members of parliament sit Iraqi
law requires a minimum number of MPs to
be present before a session can begin
instead the Speaker of the Parliament
Mohamed el Habashi
held a meeting with people who claim to
represent the
Chester's late on Saturday he held a
news conference surrounded by his party
loyalists it looked more like a campaign
rally than a press conference and with
calls for an election front protestors
and other parties Hal busi set out a
range of economic reforms and social
reforms he says his party will introduce
loans will be given in the form of
credits Bank credits be initiated for
the purposes of establishing factories
and providing equipment this will enable
us to steer away from any corruption so
facilities will not be given in cash
loans yet will be credit for the
establishment of factories the speak is
not alone in trying to appeal to the
protesters there are key politicians of
all stripes and religious leaders appear
to be throwing their support behind the
protest movement but it's not clear if
the protesters will accept them given
the fact that they blame the same
politicians for the die economic
situation that's sparked at their
protest in the first place and the
government for violence's like these
what Emran joins us live now from
Baghdad so what's the mood there on the
streets right now
well we've seen protests take place here
in Baghdad in the early hours of the
morning once again shots have been
ringing out live fire has been used
we've also heard about protests in the
rest of the south of the country in fact
in NASA Rhea and this is very
interesting what the protesters did was
not just attack government buildings but
they attacked political party
headquarters which they burnt and now in
NASA Rhea they're chanting and now Surya
is free of political parties and that's
crucial because there is a political
crisis brewing here as well a lot of the
opposition politicians a lot of the
religious parties are taking a look at
this protest movement and they're
thinking to themselves it's not going
away if anything it's getting bigger and
more popular and they're trying to
appeal to the protest in his protesters
in my report that you heard Mohammed Al
Hal busi the Speaker of the Parliament
he's been even more explicit in last a
few hours saying
that he wants to join the protest
movement now whether the protest
movement actually take him to heart
considering they actually blame
politicians of all hues for the problems
remains to be seen but what we're seeing
now is the biggest challenge to prime
minister I'd love the almighty's year
old government
he's appealed for calm he wants the
protesters to give him a chance to put
in place reforms that he says will
change things that's not good enough
for the protesters so what it feels like
is that we are seeing Iraq's politicians
or our religious parties see a sense
sense a change in Iraq and they're
looking to see what they should do next
and it seems to me and it seems to a lot
of Iraqis that they're actually going to
try and support the protest movement all
right Imran Khan life was there in
Baghdad thanks